What do you think you're doing, boy?
The girl's life is now mine.
I'm sure she'll make
a lovely wife for you.
There's a demon inside of you.
It's inside both of you.
Look, everyone!
This is what hatred looks like. This is
what it does when it catches hold of you.
It's eating me alive,
and very soon now it will kill me!
Fear and anger
only make it grow faster.
I'm getting a little bored
of this curse of yours, Ashitaka.
Let me just cut the damn thing off!
Lady Eboshi!
Someone come here
and take her from me.
Milady!
Don't worry. She's just stunned.
She'll be all right.
As for me, I'm leaving,
and I'm taking the Wolf Girl!
No, you're not!
Nobody treats my Lady Eboshi like that!
Move and I fire!